[Music]
we need
cop the world needs him
she's the only one he'll communicate
with
[Music]
it's godzilla
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
i saw something out there
[Music]
someone
[Music]
the largest organism on the planet lives
right here
[Music]
growing waiting
and it's ready to spread
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
first learned about this seven years ago
on a mission in brazil
to capture a wanted fugitive
when we got there it tore through our
unit in seconds
the target has superhuman abilities
[Applause]
[Music]
it had the same marking you do cole
it's a birthmark what do you mean he was
born with it
it's not a birthmark cole means you've
been chosen
[Music]
throughout history different cultures
all over the world
reference a great tournament
of champions that dragon marking
i think it's an invitation to fight for
something known
that's mortal kombat
these are your champions i'm sonya
that's kano i'm luke
name's
[Applause]
no matter how many of my people you put
in the ground
we will not fail kill them
i am sub-zero
get over here
the world has a way of changing but
there's one thing
that always stays the same you miss the
old life
deal every day
crank it all the way up
[Music]
the bells didn't rub
up in the dark among the stars
the god is dead
[Music]
i had a dream
almost like a premonition
i think there's an attack coming my lord
this world will fall
[Music]
i need warriors i'm building an alliance
to defend ourselves
how do you know your team's strong
enough if you can't bring down the
charging bull
then don't wave the red cape at it
[Music]
you're sitting here for a reason
and even if it takes you the rest of
your life
find out what that reason is
they said the age of heroes would never
come again
it will it has to
we live in a society where honor
is a distant memory isn't that right
[Music]
batman
are we there yet this beach it's
beautiful
my swimsuit is hurting they do look
small come on let's play hide and seek
have you seen my children mom i'm right
here
he was six years old this morning oh no
mom i'm scared there's something wrong
with this beach we were chosen for a
reason
what's happening
own only in theaters this summer
from the very beginning i realized i saw
the world differently than everyone else
[Music]
that didn't sit well with some people
but i wasn't for everyone
[Music]
i guess they were always scared that i'd
be
a psycho
but a new day brings new opportunities
and i was ready to make a statement
how does the same girl
i am woman hear me raw
i'm just getting started darling
the thing is i was born
[Music]
i'm
this valentine's day you are the cutest
couple don't be afraid
what is he doing to shake things up
[Music]
this year it is not a crazy idea that
you two can get along
let your frenemy know how you really
feel
tom and jerry the movie
just discovered that i may have a son
here in this land how much child support
she getting from the king pays no child
support no child support for 30 years
and you came back
use a dummy
here hello i am nakeem jaffa king of
zamunda
you are the heir to the throne yes yeah
he's supposed to be like the prince of
wakanda wakanda is a fictional place not
to everybody
has a very real nation i don't need no
handouts
wait a minute all right
and my mom's and his moms
children this is your brother hey kwai
i'm sorry i slept with your man this
happened before we even met
it's not like you're the first man i've
ever been with i haven't
what did you just say about the other
men coming to america now it's coming to
me i always thought that
mika was going to be queen a woman isn't
allowed to rule zamunda it's the law
did it ever occur to you that megan
wanted to be your heir
would you dare banish me from my own
bedroom
[Applause]
how are you doing i'm getting it from
everywhere
i am upset in my family you must
be strong and general izzy would love
nothing more than to take over zamunda
raise it higher
i must admit your style is far into my
kingdom but it's impressive
that's right there you go let me hear
you say hey ho hey ho
no no no that's his mother oh don't you
say no not to his mother
i'm almost ready to become a prince
almost it is fine
ceremonial circumcision
ain't gonna sharpen you too nephew
[Music]
six years of searching please let this
be it
whoa focus eyes forward took
good boy okay so here's the stitch
this is kumandra each land is named
after a part of the dragon
fang heart spine tail
and talon we were once unified
harmoniously as one
until evil forces were awakened
shattering the peace and dividing the
five lands
raya this isn't the world i want you to
live in
to restore peace i must find the last
[Music]
dragon
we need you to defeat the evil with the
last of dragon magic
ah i'm gonna be real with you all right
i'm not like the
the best dragon okay
we need to keep going see the world's
broken
world warriors assassins and pickpockets
[Music]
you can't trust anyone maybe it's broken
because you don't trust anyone we really
need your help
my girl ryan and i are gonna fix the
world yes i too wish to join this
fellowship with particularly
hold on oh we were doing a jumpy thing
sorry it may
feel impossible but sometimes you just
have to take the first step
i just shave change dragons can do that
look how close my butt is to my head
it's gonna make digestion so much faster
in cinemas or ordered on disney plus
with premier access
[Music]
good evening
[Music]
oh wait you're just a civilian now
mr james ford general ryan's requesting
your
inimitable counsel no
he's offered to reinstate you
from the top four hours ago the crew the
vander made first contact
stay there
in the event of first contact humanity
must strike first
to ensure the continued survival
of our species operation cosmic sin
is now a go but there
is a space gate they can bring their
army here
what's the status of the cuba if we want
to launch the cue bomb
we need to get into orbit suit's up
that's something huh we didn't know
whether to burn it or put it in a museum
i'm sure they said the same thing about
me
if we leave that door open we're gonna
charge in
we can make this the kill box
i'm not gonna wait for them to bring the
fight to us
we're gonna take it to them what we do
here
is easy
the hard part is living with it
[Music]
what does kepler teach this louise
we will not think about ourselves
we will not let our emotions guide us
we do this for the many
she was called mother earth
we plundered everything she offered
all reproductive efforts fail for both
men and women
they want to prove that we can procreate
here
survivors
why are you following me i want to help
you
we waited so long i'm so pleased that
you're here with us now
it's imperative now that we bring our
people
[Music]
are they coming
[Music]
the human race doesn't need us to
survive
are you still with us blake
none of us should have come back
[Applause]
[Music]
we're preparing a major offensive our
task is to draw out the germans
they must be made to believe that this
is where the attack will take place that
is why you
have to retake the village at any cost
i've lost half my man i didn't ask you
how many men you have left in your
company
i asked if you understood your orders
i'll give you and your company
a chance to earn your place in history
we must make them see that we can do
more than just retreat
that we
we can't retreat commander you're right
we can't
[Music]
explain this i feel us you have to leave
now
with
[Music]
this is litvar
there is something very very wrong here
we have to go now
it won't let you live
mrs litvac what won't let me leave
say magic
[Music]
will find another broken person
[Music]
you